so so many different directions you
could go with the film about Fred Rogers
but my Kanoa my understanding is the
slice that you decided to take on it
came from research you did and a series
of letters can you talk about finding
those letters and what it was about them
that made you think this is the
direction we need to go in yeah so we've
been working on this movie for for 10
years it'll be 10 years in January and
in the course of those years we found
ourselves trying to fight trying to find
the right way into this story we
realized quickly that Fred Rogers was
was not the ideal subject for this
traditional kind of three act biopic
that we actually needed to do was to
look at the people in Fred's life who's
whose life he effected and we were in
Latrobe Pennsylvania in the western part
of the state where Fred Rogers archive
is where he grew up and we had read Tom
Juno's article before but what we hadn't
actually we hadn't actually seen was
this this trove of letters we were there
in the archive we were wearing these
sort of cotton archival gloves to make
sure we didn't get our hands on
everything and and in this box were
about 200 letters that Fred and Tom
exchanged over the course of five years
until Fred died in 2003 and it was deep
it was about everything it was about
this relationship that we built the
movie into and we said this is the movie
that first scene that set up that guy
took my breath away
Mario key but it felt like it had to be
a little bit of a risk with such an icon
such an American treasure and then you
open up the pocket door and you see
Lloyd's battered face talk about your
approach well we we never really
questioned that this was gonna be the
opening the movie that we were gonna
start with this kind of larger framing
device which I loved in the script but
once we filmed it we realized I think
what a risk it was both in just starting
right out the bat with
Tom Hanks coming in the door we realized
that audience's minds were kind of doing
acrobats because you start the movie and
you you see this the familiar miniature
and the stoplight and the couch and it
all feels like oh I recognize this this
look exactly like I remember and then
the door opens and you see Tom Hanks and
you're like no that's not it and you
have a moment where your brain has to
kind of catch up and we realized
everyone has to has to get used to this
guy as this person that they loved and
we figured out we had a moments where we
kind of toyed with is is this the right
approach to the beginning of the movie
or not but we realized we got to go in
the deep end you kind of gotta have you
just have to get used to this and so
we're gonna sit with it and we're gonna
sit with it for a long time and we're
gonna do it all in one take and we're
gonna really take our time and yes and
then we have this moment where you open
the picture door which was a real
episode of mr. Rogers where he had this
very similar looking picture door so
this very familiar thing if you're very
familiar with the program that he did
and then having this introduction to
Lloyd with his bloody face
I don't know I just I thought it was
great I loved it but we knew it was
weird it was also challenged on the day
cuz it's against your instinct like we
had multiple cameras and you wanna also
it was not easy for Tom to go through
and Mari really was so disciplined to
keeping us all on track because you have
an instinct of being like well let's
let's make it a little bit easier let's
cut let's move around and to just be
kind of you know to keep the integrity
of it what was it we worked with the
rules of the show yeah and they shot the
show in very specific ways so for
example we had three cameras we filmed
on these old Tube cameras that they
filmed on and the way they would film on
the original show is someone was calling
live and you know one camera would light
up on top and that was the camera that
was live so that's what we did
yeah but we could have filmed to all
three cameras but we didn't because we
really wanted it to be that he was only
looking at whichever camera was on and
that it had that sort of cutting pattern
and if you're cutting you know if you
were cutting to another camera he
wouldn't be looking it it was sticking
to difficult rules
in order to stick with the authentic
recreation of the show which sounds like
it was important it's our jump in here
for a moment because anybody who's ever
encountered Tom Hanks he works at a
different pace and a different rhythm
than that and maybe not can you talk
about the difference between Tom and
real-life Tom on that screen and Mari
maybe you could talk about how you got
him there well I can't I can speak to on
behalf of Tom Hanks for the first time
and say that Mari was like with the
reigns going as she kind of and he said
he struggled that's it his his temper he
moves at the speed of light as you said
and for him to take his time took a
great great deal of effort he does I
mean you guys have similar energy in
real life like you're both really quick
you're always joking around there's a
lot of energy Tom drinks a lot of coffee
and and the idea in casting Neal was
we're trying to get opposite energies in
many ways we were trying to kind of show
these two men who are foils for each
other who's both believe that they're
helping the world but they have
different perspectives on how they're
helping the world one inherently
believes people are good and one
inherently believes people are bad and
that their job is to expose that truth
to the world and but that part of that
is that there has to be this meeting of
these two energies and thus these two
worlds Pittsburgh in New York Tom and
Lloyd it's these two sides of a coin and
um that did mean with Tom it's not just
slowing him down though it was actually
kind of changing his like DNA his energy
of his whole body I mean it was really
finding stillness because what happens
when you slow down a fast person is it
comes out in like little ways you know
like you it has to go somewhere so it
was really like a meditation every day
to kind of pull him into a different way
of being almost like doing Tai Chi or
something but it was actually kind of
slowing his whole being down can you
talk about I mean I'd love to hear from
you too about how that impacted how do
you think the film came out because it
could have potentially be filmed
anywhere but it wasn't
I was just gonna say like it's all in
line with this the sort of the
beginnings of this project which were we
couldn't do this by ourselves we had to
have the Fred Rogers estate and his
widow Joanne and Bill Iser who ran his
company they all needed to be part of
this and they all needed to not only
give us the thumbs-up
but like kind of hold our hands as we
went through it like it was very
important to us which is one of the
reasons why it took ten years and so I
think like we came with that energy so
Joanne and was was giving it back yeah
there were times when I remember I was
up with Arjun and Jade Healey our
costume designer and our production
designer in Joanne's apartment and
Joanne would just be handing this
artwork say Oh Jade here this could be
for the so-and-so set and Arjun are at
one point she invited Arjun and I to go
in and actually just pick whatever we
wanted out of the closet which was still
stuff of Fred's there and it was just
amazing to be there and open up the
closet and be able to walk through and
Argent's pulling ties out and all that
stuff and like mari had said a lot of
that stuff is in the movie it's either
in the set or it's um you know it's or
Tom's well I think it just made us feel
good Little Mix mr. McFeely bag that he
wears was the real mr. McFeely bag and
David Noah came to set that day and
brought the back and get he wore the bag
and it's not just the props it's also
the people um in the in the scene in the
Chinese restaurant that's actually
Joanne Rogers that's the real abilities
ler that's Margie and heta who worked
with Fred for many years we when the
when the camera sweeps around we we
invited them there that day to sort of
hold that space for for all of us and
shooting in the studio was like married
mentioned it was you could really feel
the vibes there I did I felt like that
it was yeah we felt like we felt Fred
the reverberations of Fred everywhere we
went one of the things I mean this is
obviously a film about Fred Rogers but
this is also very much a film about
fatherhood and I'm curious as a father
Matthew what it was love a young boy I
mean because you don't see a lot of I
feel genuine depictions of new
parenthood and fatherhood I mean even
that moment of is the baby
oh thank God that they acknowledged the
baby's asleep because in in most TVs and
films like the baby just disappears but
as a mother I'll tell you that never
happens so what was it like for you
Matthew yeah no you you Mari was very
strong on that point you know the scene
where one with the milk and you'd said
time and time again I you don't see this
in movies and we have to do this and it
should be addressed and it should be a
journey for you to go on through
throughout the film as the kind of the
deep kind of research of Fred Rogers I
did in thinking I certainly was one type
of parent and you know I my parents were
great but I thought I would never be
like them and then I realized I was
absolutely like them and as a result of
of Fred Rogers Fred Rogers fell off his
philosophies I hope that I have slowed
myself a little more and listen and
don't tell my three-year-old about
everything I mean we're all parents here
so so much of what we were doing when we
were working on the script and in the
early prep phases was talking about what
this meant to us as parents particularly
and Lloyd's journey was so relatable to
me because I think this big emotional
thing happens for a lot of us when you
have a kid for the first time where your
own childhood comes into reflection in
this major way who you want to be in the
world your own mortality like all this
stuff comes crashing in and we don't
talk about that you talk all about the
kid but you don't really talk about what
your own emotional journey is when you
became a parent and how potent that
period of time is made worse by the fact
that nobody is sleeping but it is like a
very it's a very potent emotional time
and there was this idea for me of we
only see certain versions I mean that
what you pointed out is exactly
something that makes me crazy of like
why is it why doesn't why is there never
a baby crying why is that baby always
ignored you know that we we don't show
true depictions of children we also
don't show a really wide variety of
masculinity on screen for me part of the
appeal of making a movie about Mister
Rogers was it's a version of masculinity
that scares a lot of people he has ways
of being that people might traditionally
think of as more feminine and but also
with Lloyds characters show
a man who's try his version of trying to
become better is not just to become
better at his job or what it's also
trying to become a better human being
and a better father and a better husband
and these images of him it shouldn't be
radical but it weirdly feels radical to
show a man caring for his baby
warming-up milk singing to his baby
crying hugging his father saying I'm
sorry saying I love you you know I grew
up with men for whom this is not
something that's rare you know I grew up
with feeling men in my household and I'm
married to a feeling man but I don't
know on stage with some and I'm on stage
with a whole line of them who wrote this
beautiful movie but I don't feel like we
see that on screen I mean this isn't a
version of masculinity we get to see we
don't get to honor that version of men
and we talked early on about how
important that was to all of us not to
late turn this into some kind of group
therapy but that's sort of what the
making of this movie was I mean I think
it has informed in profound ways the
ways that we approach parenting
ourselves you know when you're I think
our natural instinct when your kid is
you know having feelings as sad as upset
is screaming as crying is to say you
know don't do that let me distract you
away from these from these feelings
let me fill this void let me fill this
silence with something and I think what
Fred Rogers taught us as parents or
taught me as a parent is that your job
as a as as a father is not to deny those
feelings but to make your child feel
safe in them and to hold space for your
child and and that is I think
spiritually what we're trying to do in
the movie is to hold space for feelings
I think it was the genesis as well I
mean what you're talking about Mari was
you know when we started I was like a
brand-new dad and not very good at it
and I think that the insecurities that I
was feeling you know I had a newborn and
it and it almost two-year-old and in
sort of a moment of I don't know what
else to do I put on Fred Rogers and my
super stubborn two-year-old turned to
the screen and started doing
calisthenics with Fred and I was like
mica this guy this Fred Rogers is a
warlock and he speaks toddler and we
must write about him thank you all for
such a beautiful film